in this video we've got to discuss the  2022 macbook lineup which seems like  it's about to get more extensive and  confusing than ever before mark german  says that there's going to be a new  version of the entry-level macbook pro i  think it totally makes sense for the new  m2 macbook pro to get the exact same  display and design as the 14 inch m1 pro  macbook pro let's get into my  predictions for the pricing of apple's  entire 2022 macbook lineup m1 macbook  air 999 starting price brand new  redesigned m2 13 inch macbook air either  11.99 or potentially up to 12.99 the new  air will be sold alongside the current  m1 macbook air m2 14 inch macbook pro  either 13.99 or 14.99 i fully believe  that apple is not going to be upgrading  the current 14 and 16 inch m1 pro  macbook pro models until 2023